[Musique]
le soleil
sow
oh
à
santé
et
ça y est
[Musique]
m
là
et
[Musique]
l'api ayant retrouvé le corps cachés
dans la forêt chez nono l'écureuil d'où
deux parlent de la ferme et se
souviennent et vous vous souvenez madame
l'appui de la colère dit fermiers
proposent chacune a pu être drôle
[Musique]
oui à la papa parce qu'il a pu être
drôle ce matin aucun nom ah non ce matin
il m'a regardé d'un drôle d'air n'a
l'air qui m'accusaient au les hommes et
voulions enfin ici les oiseaux sont très
gentils et je suis très heureux si
heureux que ça mais oui si heureux que
ça croyez vous que je regrette la ferme
et ses fermiers incapable de m'apprécier
et qui veulent me manger pas si
incapable que ça que voulez vous dire
et bien ce matin le fermier a dit 'oui'
at-il donc notre vieux coq c'était un
bon et fidèle serviteur il a dit ça coco
ho ho ho ho que je suis content il a
vraiment dit ça parce que vous savez
allons allons compères cessé de jouer la
comédie
vous savez bien que vous ne demandez que
ça que quoi rentrer à la ferme
bon peut-être que oui peut-être que non
ça dépend
c'est tout redevient comme avant si je
n'entends plus parler de coq au vin
alors cessez donc de re goûter vous
mourrez d'envié de revenir à la ferme
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs votre fille aînée est en
train de couver vous allez être
grand-père gropper noah modem l'appui
bien sûr que je veux rentrer à la ferme
le devoir m'appelle ma fille a besoin de
moi je n'hésite plus je rentrerai demain
pourquoi pas maintenant parce que nono
l'écureuil donne une fête en mon honneur
tous mes amis sont invités
vous êtes aussi invités merci j'accepte
mais demain soyez tranquilles madame
pipi
quand le devoir m'appelle je n'hésite
jamais
venus tous voir les préparatifs de la
fête ses magnifiques chansons bleu
soleil est là et la paie la note
[Musique]
allez
tél
[Musique]